bueno esta explanada es particularmente
un lugar sagrado para judíos y
musulmanes pero en medio de estas
tensiones podría comprenderse también
como un símbolo de soberanía para ambas
partes
es súper importante que la audiencia
entienda que la razón también en donde
la religión fluye con la política y ex
as
pequeño confluyen pilares fundacionales
en las tradiciones las creencias
religiosas de las principales religiones
monoteístas del rey explicó que no salen
es una ciudad sagrada tanto para el
judaísmo el catolicismo y el islam y
estamos en un momento donde se celebra
la semana santa la princesa por la
pascua judía y el ramadán islam entonces
para el catolicismo los episodios más
emblemáticos de la vida la muerte y la
resurrección de cristo transcurren allí
para la tradición judía en jerusalén en
la ciudad fundada por el rey david y lo
que hoy se conoce como la explanada de
las mesitas el lugar sagrado donde
originalmente fue puesto a prueba la fe
de ahora y donde supuestamente iba a
sacrificar a su hijo isaac y
adicionalmente el sitio que se
construyen los dos templos sagrados de
los modismos que posteriormente iban a
ser destruidos a lo largo de la historia
y que terminaría con que la diáspora
judía en el siglo primero de la era
cristiana y para el islam jerusalén
conducía en árabe como el coach
serás las más importante después de la
meca y medina y des fundamentalmente
sagrada porque hacia la jerusalén se
estableció la primera actividad y sin la
dirección hacia donde el profeta mahoma
ingresado al inicio de la fe islámica
aunque eso después cambiará
posteriormente hacia la meta y media